ei ragazzi che così buio come succede
che lui
così nei fatti
cioè
una lettera qui da quella di hogwarts
san lorenzo che mandiamo un regalo
spaziale ma che gli spazi e occupa ben
poco già chiedo soffri di tasche troppo
piene questo è lo smartphone che fa per
te non ci credi 16 alla prova un saluto
vodafone pregavo il samsung galaxy z 35
g quello che no no no questo esempio di
questa questa magia incredibile occupa
poco spazio
restiamo la questa cosa giusta
l'articolo che telecomando
e con la mia tasca destra piena solo
quella destra perché in carica c'è stato
tutto lì ti faccio vedere il mio samsung
galaxy z flip 35 g che praticamente fa
questa cosa
technology è uno schermo di 6.7 pollici
che diventa la meta una volta chiuso che
ho fatto la matematica elementare almeno
almeno quella ha un peso ridotto di
183 g che lo rendono nei termini più
versatili sempre calcolati va non
fategli ovviamente ingannare dalle
dimensioni perché qua dentro c'è tutto
quello di cui avete bisogno tra cui la
fotocamera frontale a 12 megapixel con
la possibilità di utilizzare in modalità
self i se si chiude il telefono
ovviamente perché
technology e per i veri appassionati di
gaming c'è anche il display a 120 hearts
e 8 gb di ram se volete appunto giocare
con l'offerta speciale vodafone che
trovate in descrizione potete prendere
sia questo ma anche questo che il set up
oltre e si apre
così però troppa tecnologia oggi ragazzi
non vorrei troppo diventare un cane tech
passiamo al gameplay let's go michael
boys mai dubbi rispetto sono i noiosi
l'inglese lento ma che la donna di
ragazzi su aiger lower che è quel co
quel coso quel sito del gioco dove devi
indovinare quale delle due cose più
cliccata su internet ma appunto dovrebbe
conoscerlo perché una volta l'ho portato
un sacco infatti in questi giorni sto
facendo un sacco di revaival di titoli
che portava una volta così nostalgia
time vediamo se riesco a fare un
punteggio decente come facevo una volta
nota era veramente un campioni stavano
infatti la [ __ ] pioveva oggi
giochiamo tra allora altro avvicinati pn
teller famosissimi penne teller che
sarebbero ipantellas oppure wikileaks
credo ovviamente l'utilizzo wikileaks
cercato con un sacco di cose ed altro
queste ricerche ragazzi si basano sul
tra parentesi su l'anno 2017 quindi devo
anche mentalmente tornare al 2017 per
funzionare per funzionalità roma quindi
vediamo comunque è wikileaks un evento
ovviamente wikileaks mazza però anche me
m complimenti a christopher nolan
memento o palestina gli stati sono
sempre cercati abbastanza almeno mezzo
milione quindi un driver per la
ricordavamo sta cosa però va questo the
salvation army
credo palestina absolute lei ma non solo
d'estate share armi o lemming silei mix
sarebbero tipo warns giochino vecchio
più lemmings yes man
mamma mia il giocatore è profittevole
dovrebbe essere cercato parecchio perché
è una ricetta
però mammamia dei lemming se veramente
cercato quindi meno
pari pari madonna giochiamo è lei miss
mentre mangiamo i profiteroles
profittevole o make up
non lo so non era profittevole non era
profittevole bastiglia franchi ma con un
punteggio di 6 non ci lamentiamo da una
vita in un gioco ci può stare a pete
sampras o teletubbies ripartiamo
stavolta guarda che c'hanno una roba da
dingo pixels sulla caccia va bene te
davis ma trovai ma quanti click i
teletubbies porca vacca super anime
contro tutte quasi teletubbies o
ricchezza so perché qualcuno che cerca
ricchezza i teletubbies si portano a
casa un sacco di soldi reali colori e i
mezzi non ho mai notato star golosa
teletubbies ovviamente la ricchezza e
cercata quanti lemmings quanto il
profittevole meccanico o anche a luca
meccanico madonna le quali pay day long
sono la sera ora ma porca [ __ ] perché
sbaglio sempre a 51 56 vabbé vabbé
labbra york arriva dieci non mi dite
cosa di stato la gravidanza
adolescenziale e viventi ory credo
viventi che abbia almeno almeno tre
milioni e mezzo di click due milioni e
mezzo pensavo molto di più probabile
devilman theory ed epilessia va bene
quindi mi metti ore sicuro ok a posto è
qui che si è complici
ma io che cosa credo non lo so penso di
lessi a
casa centro calato twin peaks e 2017 ma
cosa sia un punteggio di me cose non me
lo dire per favore un attimo li
rimettiamoci il sesto perché so che già
questo fa natale scott molto grosso re
nutriv motocross e fin qua renaul clio o
put noodle renaul clio perfetto
non so cosa sia ma con la destra
ok perfetto
ps 4 più del madonna ps4 un po tanto che
prefetto jay chou molto meno
ok
festa della mamma molto di più perché
nessuno si cura mai quando è quindi
valutati googlare perfetto milgram
experiment non so cosa sia ma chi se ne
frega meno e abbiamo tutto il record di
giornata dai
ditemi che l'avete capita dai vi prego è
ovviamente quello a destra perfetto 1
milione tutti i meritatissimi perché
l'ho con correrei la mattina sera tokyo
tokyo almeno un milione e mezzo living
mica coppa paschi il torchio proprio a
occhio a me l'ha affittata dico ai
ragazzi questa è la giocata io ve la
chiamo la chiamo prima di farla questa
la giocata diamo almeno 15 ma dico
subito messico o find my iphone questo è
quando la ragazza incinta cerca il
ragazzo su find my iphone lo trova in
messi meno no di più per almeno veniva
chiamata la giocate incredibili white
saint just jurassic park
dinosauri a edith avrà quegli 8 milioni
11 por qué troy bell penso che cosa sia
meno se mi dispiace charles darwin
leclerc che vuole comunque meno chris
evans o charles darwin
mi spiace chris evans youtube e credo
che youtube si aggiri attorno alle
18 milioni
ok warren harding meno meno orario
strano perché pensava forse di più
coffee shop ho allenato ai coffee shop
di più ok ragazze ma 7 calmi johnson and
johnson molto di più poi con i vaccini
hanno in realtà no perché voi non ci
hanno prima c ma comunque almeno quegli
8 milioni
[Musica]
nice day che il cristo redentore il
birthday cake cristo redentore the
pressure depresso deflation che quella
che c'è qui adesso deerhunter deflation
tirantello le unghie per le cure
il rake las vegas tatuatori new england
nessuno si tatua 2017 smettila 6 che led
kamorrah days che leggerlo cuoce la
festival con cella festival no volte a
terra e los angeles
lacma dai
dai
clamidia dai meno porca [ __ ] dai
genna di più dai ragazzi vi prego e
vedrà me almeno l'ultima meno lucia
coincidenza ma perché la gente cerca
coincidenza ma cosa chi è sembra mio zio
new anti amnesty di più
santander almeno 6 milioni ragazzi 20
milioni va bene pantera rosa ma per non
importa dai
71 67 bit le cascate vittoria
me lo avevi normale meno male meno male
dellimauri più 8
bastano 20 metri bowie 9
sono dieci l'ho fatto l'ho fatto ho
fatto io ci ho fatto dieci quasi score
10 score 10 proviamo un 11 mag
abbiamo sfondato il muro detiene online
poker di più di ted sicuro no ok va bene
l'ascoltatore bastava bene poi è bello
che mi escono sapreste su pubblicità
ogni volta incredibile reiko ragazzi era
30 vi dico solo questo incredibile ma io
mi sia piaciuto ragazzi come se c'è
fiducia io mi piace anche alla risorsa
che coniglio tutta la descrizione se non
si discute come sempre ci vediamo al
prossimo video e ragazzi
[Musica]